it's now against the law to buy sex in
France but selling sex not a crime this
controversial law is playing into a
worldwide debate about sex workers and
boils down to this is the sex worker a
criminal or is the client and should any
part of sex work be illegal or should it
all be decriminalized France has joined
Norway Iceland Sweden and Northern
Ireland in adopting the view that those
selling sex deserve protection and not
prosecution and that it's a person who's
looking to buy sex who's breaking the
law the reasoning behind these laws is
that since most sex workers are
exploited by traffickers pimps or
desperate circumstances they shouldn't
be penalized for being essentially
victims French officials point out that
90% of sex workers in the country are
trafficked from Romania China and
Nigeria it's also estimated that up to
4.5 million people worldwide are in
situations of forced sexual exploitation
the other part of the Nordic approach is
rehabilitation instead of punishment so
helping sex workers reintegrate into
society build skills and find work in
other professions but not everyone
supports these new measures in fact some
of the loudest opponents sex workers
themselves some sex workers are arguing
that these laws are ineffective in
protecting them from violence and that
they undermine the movement for total
legalization of sex work for them
neither the sex worker nor the client
should be considered a criminal
they say criminalizing any aspect of sex
work just pushes it underground making
it more dangerous and some human rights
groups agree Amnesty International has
argued for full decriminalization of all
aspects of sex work meaning that no one
should face punishment if it's
consensual the Netherlands and New
Zealand have adopted this approach but
it's the Nordic model still that's
taking hold the European Union for
example has recommended it be adopted by
all of its member countries meanwhile in
the United States sex work is illegal in
every state except Nevada so what's the
best way to make sure that sex workers
aren't exploited
you